[Music]
all right hello everyone uh thank you
for making it out and I hope you've had
a great Google Cloud next so far um
before we get started I just want you
all to know this presentation will be
about 30 minutes and then afterward you
all can uh queue up and ask questions at
the microphone over there um I'm Cameron
and I am the product lead for the go
programming language at Google uh today
we're going to discuss software supply
chain security what it is why it matters
and how the tools we ship with the go
programming language can help you secure
your software supply chain at every
stage of the software development life
cycle before we get started a second
about me uh as I said I'm the PM lead
for go I've been on the go team for a
little over three years before go I was
on the Google Cloud SDK uh I led uh
languages and Frameworks Integrations
and the SDK in general uh and before
Google I was a software developer at uh
prop trading firm um I worked on high
frequency low latency trading strategies
and C++ and a little bit of java and now
I'm a go convert um the security
features that I'll dig into during this
presentation are just a small part of
why I like go a whole lot more than the
other stuff I've worked
in now I'm sure most of you know what go
is but it's helpful to start this
presentation by telling you why go
started at Google in the first place and
the first and probably most important
point that I want to make about it is
that go is not just a programming
language it is a complete endtoend
platform for building production systems
that was true in the beginning and it's
still true today so we'll begin with the
beginning now I wasn't there
but the legend is that during a
45-minute C++ build sometime in 2007 Rob
Pike and Robert Greer scribble together
a vision of what would ultimately become
go if you've never heard of Robert or
Rob Robert was previously known for his
work as the principal architect of the
Java hotspot virtual machine and also on
the V8 JavaScript uh engine Rob Pike was
known for a lot of stuff out of bell
Labs including his work on the Unix team
and the plan 9 operating
system the two of them along with Ken
Thompson who co-invented Unix along with
Dennis Richie they're all known as the
co-creators of go so anyway according to
rob a couple of Google employees had
recently given a talk on all the new
stuff that was coming out in C++ 11 and
in the span of about an hour he counted
something like 35 new features that were
being planned and somewhere in there he
asked himself a question
did the C++ committee really believe
that what was wrong with C++ was that it
didn't have enough features surely it
would be a greater achievement to
simplify the language rather than to add
to
it now Rob made this observation in the
midst of a period of tremendous growth
at Google the breath of Google's
products and services was growing usage
was growing and the engineering teams at
Google that built and maintained all
that stuff was growing too so that meant
a lot more people writing a lot more
code and coordinating all of that
carried a whole lot of new
overhead and since Google's business is
all about scale this problem was only
going to get
worse and this is where go was born
Google was struggling with its scale the
complexity of a massive code base with
so many developers working on the same
projects in Java and C++ had led to
brittle code and diminished productivity
and Go's Vision was hey let's prioritize
this scale and that means accounting for
how modern software is architected the
environments in which modern workloads
run and most importantly the teams who
write operate and maintain it
all so on that basis from when Rob and
Robert started in 2007 to when go1 was
released in 2012 the go team worked to
Define Go's founding principles and
build it for release so this includes
making an source project which we did in
2009 and then ensuring that what we call
go 1.0 is usable in part by putting it
in
production now one of the key bits in
Google a go one's release notes was this
emphatically stated point the driving
motivation for go1 is stability for its
users people should be able to write go
programs and expect that they will
continue to compile and run without
change you know some programming
languages are good good at this some are
not we're going to be really good at
it and in fact we released go1 with a
separate document that explains our
compatibility guidelines in more detail
we call it the go compatibility promise
and there we wrote it is intended that
programs written to the go1
specification will continue to compile
and run correctly unchanged over the
lifetime of that specification and this
has been a Hallmark of our releases ever
since you know in effect go 1.0 was a
sort of long-term release that we
continue to support any point release
that follows go 1.1 1.2 1.21 which we
just released earlier this month they
all continue to be compatible with go
1.0 and the reason the compatibility
promise is so important is because what
we sought to release in go1 was not just
a programming language but rather a
platform for software engineering so the
vision wasn't to compete with C++ on the
number of new features we could add the
vision was to facilitate real world
software engineering at scale and that's
the sort of software that's written in
teams where members come and go where
there are deadlines slas all that
stuff and that sort of engineering
really requires long-term predictability
you know not breaking existing code or
creating a Perpetual maintenance burden
it also requires accounting for the fact
that development is more than just the
programming language you use it's this
sort of multi-stage life cycle with
different intersecting tools that's the
idea of a
platform so in addition to the
compatibility promise go one shipped
with all of this stuff on the slide too
all of it out of the box so instead of
importing a third-party library for
testing or finding and agreeing on a
style guide go one started on this
mission of providing our developers an
entire platform for everything you need
to ship good scalable software ware in
teams so that was version one next
between 2012 and 2015 as developers were
beginning to to to adopt go we focused
our efforts on refining everything like
any software project the first few
versions of go had all these rough edges
and actual usage helped us see that and
for go this was a multi-year process
culminating in 2015 with go
1.5 the compiler and runtime they were
Rewritten from C to go and that's sort
of like this important WR of passage of
a programming language of this sort
where the compiler is written in the
language that it compiles the garbage L
garbage collector was revamped the
standard library was hardened runtime
performance was improved just various
things were improved or fixed
throughout but despite all this change
the compatibility promise from go one
applied as we wrote in the release notes
version 1.5 is a significant release
including major architectural changes to
the implementation despite that we
expect almost all go programs to
continue to compile and run as before
because the release still maintains the
go1 promise of
compatibility now you may have noticed
on a slide earlier that Goan already
shipped with dependency management but
in 2018 the concept of modules was
introduced which took Go's dependency
management to the next level and started
a new parallel consideration in our
development Focus
you see around this time there had been
another important development go was
becoming increasingly important in
industry for one the entire Cloud was
being built on go so this includes gcp
but it also includes AWS and Azure and
all the different important tools and
services that were becoming a core part
of cloud-based software
development Enterprises began to adopt
go as well using it for really important
business critical systems and
infrastructure and we realized that as
go was growing especially in these huge
infrastructure projects the importance
of security was growing as well so
modules were introduced and on a
conceptual level modules really
represented a fundamental shift in one
how go code was written and packaged and
two how go code especially third party
libraries was distributed and then the
ecosystem that followed
that so on this second point the change
distribution before modules you would go
get to download your dependencies
directly from their origin on GitHub or
wherever else and the introduction of
modules alone didn't change that but an
important property of modules is that
their contents for each version are
immutable and this provides
opportunities for caching and
authentication and we took advantage of
this immutability property to introduce
the go module mirror and check some
database so with the module mirror now
we could cache all these libraries and
because we know they're immutable we can
serve them much more efficiently which
makes dependency downloads faster and
then by caching them we can protect you
from your dependencies disappearing from
their original
locations separately with the check some
database we're able to store a hash of
all of the source code in all of these
dependencies all of them which allows us
to detect whether the source of the
origin has changed since we first saw it
which protects you against
man-in-the-middle attacks and other
tampering of your
dependencies now the module mirror and
checkum database they don't tell you
whether a dependency has a vulnerability
to start but by recording the hash the
first time any go user Imports that
dependency we can detect whether whether
a module changes on any subsequent
import by any go user anywhere so in
other words the bits you or anyone else
get that first time are the very same
bits that everyone gets on every
subsequent
time so we talked about modules in the
module mirror and the checkum database
around the same time as that we also
started seeing a lot of really
high-profile software supply chain
attacks this is the kind of thing where
an attacker would inject a vulnerability
in a commonly used open- Source library
and then this could affect huge swats of
a language ecosystem you can think of
log forj and Java for example and I
think if you watch developer keynote
earlier today they they were talking
about that
some and that's where I really leaned
into Go's security posture and
capabilities in go18 we introduce
support for ES bombs or software build
materials so this means that the go
compiler writes into every binary it
builds all the versions and dependencies
in the source which allows you to later
verify that everything is correct with
just the
binary in in go18 we also introduced a
builtin fuzzer the first major
programming language with Native fuzz
testing built into and integrated with
its standard tool chain you can think of
fuzzing as like a form of automated
testing that intelligently manipulates
inputs to your programs to flesh out
bugs this especially valuable when
trying to look for security
vulnerabilities and most recently we
launched our end to-end vulnerability
management system which surfaces known
vulnerabilities in your dependencies
everywhere from your IDE to runtime we
just launched this into GA last month
and I'll spend some more time showing
you more about it later in this
presentation so that brings us to today
and I should add that we did also do
another important thing in between all
of this which is of course the
introduction of
generics these were also introduced in
go18 generics were the single most
requested feature of all time and the
single most significant change ever made
to the language generics don't directly
impact security so I won't dig too deep
here but I just want to make this one
point when I showed you this slide
earlier the go compatibility promise I
glossed over a piece at the end so I
bring this up because in the Years
leading up to the release of go18 there
have been a lot of talk about doing a
relatively larger overhaul that we'd
call go2 and leading into the work that
eventually became go18 we realized this
might be goto you know generics in
particular they're not only the biggest
change we've ever made to the language
they're likely the biggest change we'll
ever make to the
language but it wasn't go to it was
go18 and the question that arose with
the caveat and the compatibility promise
was well when will goto
happen and the answer is never there
will not be a goto that breaks go1
programs there will be major revisions
like what we saw in go 1.5 and go18 but
they'll never break your programs
instead we've actually doubled down on
compatibility in go 121 which I said we
released earlier this month we included
a lot of new functionality that lets you
force compatibility with a specific
version of go so even though we promise
compatibility today you can upgrade now
whether or not you trust that promise
which ensures you get the latest
security patches at almost no risk of
breaking your
code we really believe that prior
prioritizing compatibility was the
single most important design decision we
made for go one and it's not just a
convenience or reliability or
maintainability thing it's a security
feature if upgrades are hard or require
work then it's expensive or risky to do
them and that means you won't be as
quick to fix security
problems and that sort of summarizes our
mission and the purpose of go and leads
into how we continue to pursue the core
Vision that started this project in the
first place
you know all those things we learned in
the last 13 to 14 years the things we
focused on the impact we had sort of
reduces to the mission in the title of
this slide go provides the most
productive platform for building
production
systems it's productive because it's
easy to learn and maintain and scale
across
teams it's a platform because it's more
than a language it's an end-to-end
developer
experience and it's production ready
because it's reliable efficient stable
and more
secure so let's take a look at that
security part now and in particular the
bit about software supply chain security
and the first thing is well what is a
software supply chain so most software
that we write it's composed of both the
source code that you write and then the
thirdparty libraries that you rely on as
dependencies usually a build process
combines these sources and outputs for
you package software and this in turn
can be run directly by your organization
or it can be consumed by other parties
as their
dependencies your dependencies can be
open source or they can be off the shelf
but either way they'll have contributors
and they'll have dependencies of their
own and all of this together constitutes
a software supply chain and you can be a
supplier you can be a consumer or more
likely you can be
both now increasingly the software
supply chain has itself become a vector
for attacks as I said in the last
section you can think of the attacks
you've seen in the news like log 4J or
or solar winds where some part of this
software development life cycle is
compromised these attacks all
demonstrate that there are actually
several different vulnerable surfaces in
your software supply
chain for example an attacker could
compromise your Source Code by injecting
bad code into your repository or by
compromising your Source control
system an attacker might compromise your
build system Say by injecting a
vulnerability into the compiler or the
uh the container you use to host your
build
process an attacker might compromise
your packaging for example by injecting
a bad artifact into your cicd
process and of course you can be
attacked at runtime Which is less of a
supply chain attack at this point but
like something like a Dos or something
that targets a problem in your runtime
environment so go contributes to all of
these steps and combined with other
offerings of gcp you can protect
yourself even more but for purposes of
this presentation I'm going to focus
mostly on attacks here in red uh these
are the ones in your dependencies
attacks here are like what you saw in
log 4J where vulnerability in one of the
most popular open source dependencies in
Java just caused an absolute nightmare
in the entire Java
ecosystem basically the vulnerability
allowed an attacker to launch a remote
code execution attack just by injecting
malicious code in any string that got
picked up by the log 4J logger so
anything that was logged it's extremely
simple it's easy to to pull off and you
never expect it because everyone trusted
log
4J so I'll walk through that a bit by
using an example to sort of understand
what an attack like this might look like
say you're writing package a and to do
that you depend on several other
packages which provide you some
functionality they in turn might depend
on other packages and so
on now let's say there's a vulnerability
deep in your dependency tree deep and
far away as it is this vulnerability
could have consequences for your
project and that's because the problem
isn't isolated to package K it could
affect I it could affect anything that
depends on I like BC D or E and worst of
all it could affect you because of some
problem in some Leaf package that you've
never even heard of with the web of
dependencies relying on other
dependencies getting larger and more
complicated there's lots of places to
stuff of vulnerability that affect wide
swaths of a language ecosystem this is
what we saw in log 4J and there's lots
of other examples out there in other
language ecosystems and this is in part
because dependency graphs can be really
complicated and that makes vulnerability
detection REM remediation a lot
harder so you may think that your
dependency graph looks like this but
really it probably looks more like this
dependency graphs are extremely complex
the rendering on this Slide by the way
describes kubernetes which as I'm sure
most of you know is written in
go so that's the problem now how does go
help well in go we solve for this and
other security problems by addressing it
all end to endend throughout the entire
software development life cycle and
we're able to do this because as I said
earlier go is not just a programming
language it's a platform so we can
create these endtoend Integrated
Solutions so this slide highlights some
of how we do that with sec security more
generally all of it's out of the
box and if we want to hone in on supply
chain security well we've created an
endtoend solution for vulnerability
management which as I mentioned we
released in a ga last month it's
integrated across the entire platform so
you'll see a piece of it in all the
highlighted steps
here here's what it looks like on a high
level first we have the data itself so
in order to create a comprehensive data
source of all known vulnerabilities in
the go ecosystem we pull vulnerability
data from a variety of places like
GitHub security advisories CVS from the
national vulnerability database security
releases for the go project itself and
direct reports from go package
maintainers the goal here is to create a
single source of Truth for the whole go
ecosystem vulnerabilities from all these
data sources are individually reviewed
curated and then aggregated into the go
vulnerability database when we curate
this data we ensure that the data
maintains a consistent quality and style
but we also identify for each report the
affected packages symbols and
versions by structuring the data like
this we can make the data more readable
but more importantly more actionable for
your
developers this is because a huge
proportion of the code in modern
application is actually contained in
your open source dependencies but only a
small fraction of that code is actually
in use so this means that when your
developers are investigating security
vulnerabilities odds are pretty good
that the vulnerable code is not actually
in use in other words those
vulnerabilities are not reachable and
the time is
wasted so this is where go really leads
not only is vulnerability management
built into the tool chain go goes vulner
unability management tools they
emphasize productive vulnerability
investigation because the database has
packages symbols and versions our tools
are able to detect whether these
vulnerabilities are actually invoked by
your application which saves your
developers a lot of
time and speaking of tools we've made
all of this data and functionality easy
to find and use most of all by
integrating it across all of our
developer touch points so you can learn
about the ones that might affect your
dependencies on our package site say
before you choose to use the dependency
at all you can use our command line tool
to check at the command line or in Ci or
to monitor in production and you can
detect and fix uh vulnerabilities in
your IDE as well through our integration
with our extension for vs
code so let's take a quick look at these
Integrations starting with our package
site at PKG dog
go.d so say you're on pg. go.d you're
searching for a package you might want
to pull into your
project if that package has a
vulnerability there'll be a red banner
at the top of the page giving you a
quick preview of what that vulnerability
is if you click into it you can check
the details to learn more like when it
was first introduced or what symbols are
actually
vulnerable if you're using a different
version of the module you can click on
the versions page to see what other
versions may be affected this view also
shows you which versions of the module
may suffer from other vulnerabilities as
well next we've created a command line
tool which makes using all of this data
in the in the database easy so you can
scan directly from your command line and
in your CI pipeline we call this tool go
vul check and it leverages the
vulnerability database to filter out
false positives and return to you the
stuff that you should actually
investigate this reduces a ton of noise
that makes that process so burdensome
most of the time and it works on
binaries as well so meaning you can use
this to monitor your application after
it's already in production say alerting
you to vulnerabilities that were
discovered after you already shipped
it so this is an example of what goon
looks like so up top we've invoked goon
on our project goon analyzes our
codebase and Compares all of our
dependencies against the go
vulnerability
database the first part of our output
reports back vulnerabilities that we
know affect our code base this is
determined based on which functions in
our code are actually transitively
calling the vulnerable symbols using
that symbol data from the
database the bottom half tells us about
vulnerabilities and packages that we
import but which are not called so this
is informational we aren't exposed to
the vulnerabilities in these packages
but maybe we'd like to know about them
anyway and of course we can always go
back to PKG go.d to look up these
packages uh learn more about the
vulnerabilities and get other
information so finally we've integrated
go vul Che into the go extension for
visual studio code which then allows you
to check your dependencies whether they
have vulnerabilities as soon as you
import them so if it reports a
vulnerability but you choose to keep the
dependency anyway say because you don't
think it affects you the go plug-in will
warn you again if your code does end up
invoking that vulner ility later
on this means that you can scan and fix
your vulnerabilities directly in your
editor at the very earliest stage of the
development life cycle a lot of users
tell me that this is their favorite part
because it enables developers who
otherwise never think about security to
actually begin contributing to the
security process they sort of become the
first line of
defense here's an example of what it
looks like so you can get output from go
Von in your vs code terminal like we we
have on this slide it's the same output
you would have gotten at the command
line from goone
Che or we can hover over our
dependencies in our go.mod file and
those with vulnerabilities will show you
the same information in in an
overlay and from our go do mod we then
have the option to fix the vulnerability
either by upgrading to the the very
latest version of this dependency or to
the first version of this dependency
where the vulnerability was fixed so
this makes vulnerability management
really easy to incorporate into your
existing workflows you never have to
leave your
IDE and that's goes vulnerability
management you get all of these benefits
with or without Google cloud and we
think go really sets the bar here for
what you should expect from your
language
ecosystem before we wrap up recall this
slide from earlier the solutions we dug
into they're really about securing your
dependencies the part on the bottom so
go provides a lot of other sec security
features too stuff like native fuzzing
memory safety static binaries and all of
these features they help at all these
other stages of the software development
life cycle this all provides a really
great Foundation especially for your
business critical systems and
infrastructure but if you really want to
build on top of that Foundation sort of
hard in at these other stages especially
if you're using other programming
languages in your deployment Google CL
cloud has a lot of really cool products
that I encourage you all to check out as
well you know Google Cloud Prides itself
on providing the best possible support
for go workloads it's all Google after
all and these other products work really
well to supplement your protection on
top of that for even more Security in
more
places and that's it before I take
questions uh please remember to give me
any feedback in the cloud next app good
or bad but especially
good and I hope you all found this
session useful and thank you for taking
the
time
hey